mais le temps nous pressent la
maintenance de l'an passé aux affaires
purement française avec d'abord donc
l'état de santé du président mitterrand
qui se porte comme un charme apparemment
ils parlent de santé tout à fait
satisfaisant a dit ce matin communiqué
de l'elysée le président de la
république a simplement éprouvé au cours
de ces six derniers mois une crue rajhi
droite importantes ayant entraîné des
troubles fonctionnels de l'appareil
locomoteur inférieur tu te rappelles la
traduction au médical donc de ce
communiqué c'est à dire que le chef de
l'état alors docteur cruralgie 10
l'arthrose un carte rose ou et traduit
ainsi du cloud et du real jb c'est une
un symptôme douloureux dans la région
graal c'est à dire la région de la face
antérieure de la cuisse c'est un signe
un signe d'une souffrance entre cette
souffrance est liée à une cause cette
cause on peut la recherché est
généralement situé en arrière au niveau
vertébrale sellin carte rose et l'a10
carte rose laing car trop ce qu'est ce
que c'est c'est la déformation du corps
vertébral plus exactement plutôt que du
corps des petites saillies qu'on appelle
les apophyses et que l'on traduit
généralement par des bec de perroquet
c'est ça on voit ça sur les radios c'est
des petites déformations et l'adisq
arthrose par contre c'est la teinte du
disque entre de werther et c'est cette
atteinte là qui est responsable en
général de la sciatique de la criirad j
puisque les deux joueuses peuvent être
similaires alors si le président
souffrait avait des difficultés pour
marcher s'il boîte s est à cause de ces
trois choses recettes à cause de la
rural j dont la cause est est une carte
rose et une 10 car trop apparemment cela
se soigne les cheveux cela se soigne
très très bien cela se soigne par les
traitements médicaux en général par le
repos mais c'est impossible de demander
ça à au président de la république
compte tenu de ses fonctions mais un
traitement médical approprié permet de
guérison très rapide des symptômes et je
crois que vous l'avez vous en avez vu
les résultats puisque le presto la bulle
il marche très très bien et qu'il peut
tenir des heures debout les autres
examens cardio vasculaire pulmonaire
alors on a fait tout un bilan il a été
pratiquée tout un bilan pour ne laisser
aucune zone d'ombré
le président le souhaitait ça a été fait
et les conclusions fort non
satisfaisante